there's a lot to love about living in a
big bright city people culture
late-night food but there's something
missing it's there but you can't see it
the night sky this is the story about a
small town in Colorado actually two
small towns in Colorado that are devoted
to space West cliff has a population of
564 residents and silver cliff has a
population of 575 this used to be a
mining community and then it evolved
into a railroad community and then into
a ranching community we're always
looking to do something that will bring
people into our community and lately
that seems to be we need to invest in
our sky so they made light pollution
their enemy they darken their towns so
that the night sky could become their
star attraction have you ever seen the
Milky Way that goes from Horizon to
Horizon 88% of the world's population
has never seen the Milky Way it's the
most magnificent thing in the world
that's what we see here but for the
town's to go dark they needed to cover
all of their lights not just street
lamps but the lights outside every house
in ranch near town that wasn't easy this
is a frontier town and I can tell you
frontier people don't like being told
what to do we had to win their hearts
and minds it took ten years they passed
ordinances raise money to cover the
streetlights and even build an
observatory
and the darker the town became the more
people saw the light this year
the valleys dark sky was designated as
one of the darkest in the world drawing
visitors from all over okay might need a
six-pack oh well I was really hoping
we'd be able to see Saturn beta yeah me
too that a community would decide to dim
its lights and help everyone to
appreciate the beauty of the night sky
is an amazing thing you come to a place
like this and the stars just burst and
it's remarkable not a lot of people are
lucky enough to see the dark sky as our
ancestors saw it and I feel that we're a
very special place to be able to look at
the Stars as people did thousands of
years ago it's a humbling thing suddenly
you realize you can almost touch it and
you're now a part of the bigger universe
and so it's just a wonderful experience
to see the dark skies and that's what
we're trying to preserve
[Music]